after years of infighting and insults
the console wars may be finally coming
to some sort of console truce maybe I'm
Lucy and this is your give peace a
chance gamespot news updates Shuhei
Yoshida president of Sony Computer
Entertainment worldwide studios has
discussed Microsoft's invitation to
connect xbox live and playstation
network for cross-platform multiplayer
speaking to Eurogamer Yoshida noted that
Sony has supported cross-platform
functionality between Playstation and PC
for numerous games most notably rocket
League and street fighter 5 Yoshida said
there were technical challenges that
needed to be overcome to allow
cross-platform play with Xbox one but
suggested this may not be difficult
because pc is an open platform it's much
more straightforward compared to xbox
one connecting two different closed
networks is much more complicated so we
have to work with developers and
publishers to understand what it is they
are trying to accomplish we also have to
look at the technical aspect the
technical aspect could be the easiest as
directly about whether it would work
with microsoft sony previously issued a
statement to gamespot that was in line
with what you Tschida said playstation
has been supporting cross-platform play
between PC on several software titles
starting with final fantasy 11 on ps2
and PC back in 2002 we would be happy to
have the conversation with any
publishers or developers who are
interested in cross-platform play
Microsoft's indie developer director
Chris Charla invited the cross-platform
discussions earlier this week in
addition to natively supporting
cross-platform play between xbox one and
Windows 10 games that use Xbox Live
we're enabling developers to support
cross-network play as well this means
players on xbox one and Windows 10 using
Xbox Live will be able to play with
players on different online multiplayer
networks including other consoles
so will you be playing with your ps4
chums other differences between your
consoles too vast to overcome which
games would you like to be able to play
a cross-platform let me know in the
comment or come by me on Twitter I'm
reducing James games thanks for watching
and make sure to keep an eye out for
future xbox one and playstation 4
updates on gamespot com
you